okay now open up and say ah what's the
best way to respond when you asked us a
question while working on my mouth we
understand that there's a lot of things
that are in your mouth when we do work
and it's difficult to communicate I
guess kind of just be like uh-huh or
wink that you agree I think we just do
it naturally it's a thing that we forget
that we're in your mouth what you should
not do is basically move your head or
grab our arm to tell us to stop we don't
want to hurt you with with instruments
your mouth do you judge us if we don't
brush before an appointment a lot of
people don't brush before it's pretty
obvious well it really doesn't make a
difference if you brush right before the
appointment
I personally don't judge but I do give
my patients a hard time and I'm like
yeah I can totally tell that you didn't
brush because it's gonna be a bloody
scene people have done weird things when
you were working in their mouth
yes I've actually had a patient lick my
finger while I was working on them I
couldn't believe it I was just in their
mouth working on them and their tongue
licked my finger and then they did it
again
they were definitely aware of it because
they were looking at me while they were
doing it I just went ahead and just
finished the procedure and just hope for
it to be over
no no no you do not share toothbrushes
because you can swap bacteria when you
kiss someone when you share a toothbrush
all those different things you literally
are interchanging bodily fluids and
saliva and within the saliva is a
transfer of that bacteria a lot of the
times that we even tell expecting moms
or moms who just had a child their oral
hygiene has to be on point because what
ends up happening is if their I'd oral
hygiene is poor they could transfer that
bacteria to their child
you know when they take the bottle and
they test it with their mouth they can
transfer all that so it's the same thing
goes for when you're using a toothbrush
whatever your boyfriend has in his mouth
and he has a lot of cavities and you
transfer it and you use it it's going to
you what's the best way to whiten your
teeth best way to whiten your teeth is
to go to your dentist let them know that
you're interested in doing that and they
can get you bleaching trays there are
over-the-counter products that you can
use Crest Whitestrips it's cheap it's
effective a lot of people have different
results with that that's the easiest way
to do it
do it-- is pretty good I also like
Sensodyne entryway people have sensitive
teeth I would definitely not recommend
the people in the mall by the kiosk
because what's happening is a lot of
people get themselves in some sticky
situations and they come to us
afterwards to try to fix that problem if
you're gonna do any bleaching do it
under the guidance and care of a doctor
what is the weirdest thing you found in
between someone's teeth some fish bones
that's kind of rickety could be like a
little scales I've definitely seen some
hair in some patients teeth which I
thought that was very weird
you always find food in between
someone's teeth no matter how hard they
what foods can permanently die your
teeth
anything that's gonna stain your clothes
will stain your teeth so things that are
dark like red wine coffee tea spaghetti
sauce things like that smoking if like
that's something that will also the
standard teeth as well and that's
there's a little bit more obvious just
because of where it is you can drink
with a straw if it's something like an
iced coffee or iced tea and the other
thing I recommend is just rinsing with
water afterward why does it orange juice
tastes disgusting after brushing your
teeth
toothpaste hopping ingredient calls
sodium lauryl sulfate or SLS and what
that does is it'll bind to the sweet
receptors that are in your taste buds on
your tongue so it's kind of blocking any
type of sweetness that you would have
with an orange from reaching your taste
buds so you can't perceive that it's
sweet our biting your nails bad for your
teeth
yes definitely if it's something that
you're doing daily you definitely will
start to see some little indentations in
the teeth well when you have a lot of
chips on your teeth the teeth do get
weaker when you have weak enamel it's
gonna chip even more so biting your
teeth is gonna make that worse if you
don't have insurance what's the best way
to have your teeth examined one go to a
local residency program or to go into a
dental school usually what you'll find
is they have reduced dental prices and
sometimes even if you go to a local
private office and you know discuss it
with the doctor they may be able to
negotiate some fees with you and work
with you again you want a payment plan
how do you feel about charcoal
toothpaste I wouldn't recommend it
because it is very abrasive and it can
cause wear and tear to the enamel and
that can cause your teeth to be
sensitive over time there's really no
scientific based evidence on the
effectiveness and the safety of charcoal
toothpaste that is a trend that that I
would say don't follow or you can't
follow it and then come see me and I'll
professionally whiten your teeth would
you recommend at-home teeth
straightening no I would definitely
recommend that you only do that under
the care and guidance of a dentist in a
dental office it's just like anything
else you into your own eye surgery so
why would you want to shoot your own
teeth sometimes it could be very
dangerous if you have a lot of bone loss
there are a lot of cases you know where
people come back and they're losing
teeth or teeth are shifted in the wrong
direction teeth are in bone for a reason
for protection so if you're doing that
at home on your own without any
knowledge of what to do you can be
putting yourself and your teeth at major
risk how often and long should you brush
two minutes 30 seconds in each quadrant
of the mouth at least twice a day
flossing once a day should you brush
your tongue a yes and why because it
causes bad breath if you don't and then
you end up with this like white coating
on the top of your tongue and it just
doesn't look good if you're not brushing
your tongue it's very easy for a
bacteria and food we kind of get trapped
in and the tongue this bacteria causes
bad breath plain and simple so it's just
remember to brush and floss twice a day
and I'll see you on six months
[Music]